FOR MORE ON THIS, FROM OUR 24/7
COSBY SITUATION ROOM, IS OUR OWN
HOLLY WALKER.
HOLLY!
(CHEERS AND APPLAUSE)
HEY, HOLLY, I KNOW YOU HAVE A
LOT TO SAY.
WHAT DO YOU HAVE TO SAY ABOUT
THIS?
>> FIRST OF ALL, WE HAVEN'T
FORGOTTEN ABOUT YOU, [ BLEEP ].
(LAUGHTER).
>> Larry: YEAH, YEAH.
WE -- I -- I -- I ACTUALLY
ALREADY COVERED THAT, HOLLY.
(LAUGHTER)
>> OKAY.
THEN I REALLY HAVE NOTHING TO
SAY.
(LAUGHTER)
>> Larry: REALLY?
WAIT, NOTHING?
>> I CAN'T SAY IT, LARRY.
I HAVE TO RAP IT.
(CHEERS AND APPLAUSE)
>> Larry: YOU HAVE TO RAP IT?
WHY DO YOU HAVE TO RAP IT?
>> BECAUSE COSBY HATES RAP, AND
MY MISSION IN LIFE IS TO DO
ANYTHING THAT MIGHT IRRITATE
THAT ASSHOLE.
>> Larry: OKAY.
ALL RIGHT.
(LAUGHTER)
GO FOR IT.
>> GIVE ME A BEAT.
(RAP BEAT)
AH, YEAH!
(CHEERS)
♪ I WAS CHILLIN' IN HAWAII
SIPPIN' ON A MARGARITA ♪
♪ SMOOTH AS CAN BE
LIKE GOLDEN BROWN VELVEETA ♪
♪ THEN I SAW A NEWSPAPER
HAD TO SPIT OUT MY FOOD ♪
♪ BILL COSBY CONFESSED TO USING
QUAALUDES? ♪
♪ TONS OF WOMEN VINDICATED!
I FOUND MYSELF CRYING
FINALLY, THERE'S PROOF BILL
COSBY WAS LYING! ♪
♪ DEPOSITION RELEASED
MUCH TO BILL'S CHAGRIN ♪
♪ CALL ME COPPERTONE
'CAUSE I'M RUBBING THIS
[ BLEEP ] IN ♪
(LAUGHTER)
♪ BILL COSBY IS A RAPIST
EVERYBODY WILL KNOW IT'S TRUE ♪
♪ HE SHOULD STOP DOING SHOWS
IT'S JUST NOT FUNNY ♪
♪ HELLO FRIEND
GOODBYE TO YOU ♪
♪ THERE WERE OTHER NEWS STORIES
NOTHING STUCK WITH ME ♪
♪ NOT EVEN
JARED BEING RAIDED FOR HIS CHILD
PORNOGRAPHY ♪
♪ NOTHING ELSE MATTERED
FOR 14 DAYS ALL I THOUGHT OF
WAS THE RAPIST THAT SAID
HEY HEY HEY ♪
(LAUGHTER)
♪ THE SERENA SLAM AND PLUTO UP
CLOSE MEANT ZIP ♪
♪ WHEN HE CONFESSED TO GIVING
WOMEN A DOSE ♪
♪ NOT THE WOMEN'S WORLD CUP OR
CAITLYN'S ESPY SNAG ♪
♪ NOW THAT COSBY'S GOING DOWN
LIKE THE CONFEDERATE FLAG ♪♪
>> AND I'M OUT!
(CHEERS AND APPLAUSE)
>> Larry: WOW.